So let's go back to our dig a hole example.
If we're going to dig a hole, we're really interested in 2 things.
One is how long it's going to take to dig that hole,
and 2, how much work, how many total hours it will take to dig.
If you're the only one digging this hole, these 2 things are the same.
So we have 1 worker, and perhaps it's going to take you 8 hours to finish,
and so that means overall you're going to do 8 hours of work.
But if you bring all your friends over to dig the hole with you,
the amount of time to finish and the total amount of work might be different.
So now we're going to have 4 workers,
and perhaps they'll work together for 8 hours total and thus be able to finish in 2 hours.
Thus they've finished digging this hole 4 times as fast.
We'd actually call this ideal scaling since adding 4 times as many workers
allowed us to finish 4 times as fast.
Alternatively, we might have 4 diggers, each of which gets in each other's way,
so we're not going to be quite as efficient.
So, for instance, we might have 4 workers, and together it's going to take them 4 hours to finish,
thus meaning that together they've done 16 hours of work.
Now you might reasonably ask yourself
why your instructor spends so much time talking about digging holes, and that's a fair point.
But there's a couple of important points of terminology that I want to make here.
The first is the concept of a step.
It's how long it takes to complete a particular computation--Operation Hole Digging.
The second is the total amount of work that it took to perform that computation
over all the active workers.
And so we're going to go into a little more depth in terms of the way that we define these.